[Musique]
salut c'est moi dans mon oui j'en use or
ma passion cette grosse et j'aime ça je
prends un niveau avec les copains ils
viennent le chercher
chercher elle y va et on remonte vers
[Musique]
6h50 quoi le guide qui sert à se diriger
la potence qui tient le guidon
ça tient le guidon du haut cadre et et
le guidon impotent se dire que si on
l'avait pas la potence le guidon il nous
reste à nous restera dans les mains
non
le bicross par toi c'est un loisir mais
ce que tu voudrais que ça devienne un
sport c'est un loisir si on ne pratique
pas pas ceux qui s'y intéressent mais un
peu et si on s'y intéresse beaucoup on
peut s'inscrire
c'est un sport mais qu'est-ce qu'on fait
exactement dans un club on se sent trahi
ou s'entraîne et on nous nous a point
comment être tenir les équilibres à
faire des figures mais là aussi du style
non fighting mais c'est quoi le
freestyle facile c'est des figures sur
vélo de ces soirs sangoulé quoi tenir à
léquilibre s'envoler est-ce que c'est
toi qui tu occupes d'acheter tout au
matériel
hu tout sauf les plus expertes et
comment que ça se passe tu peux nous
expliquer moi je prend de l'argent de
matière à rire
puis-je me payer ce qui ce qui me plaît
grégory as tu un conseil à donner à des
crossman et des bicross woman d'achat en
vue assez léger quand même et pas trop
cher parce qu'au début
plusieurs fois il faut s'entraîner
beaucoup beaucoup
et après on y arrive mais qu'est ce que
tu aimes bien en fait un petit cross
[Musique]